Một mùa thằng sau vụ trường tại chính miếng sốt bên xean cho biết,
tổng thống đúng đăng trâm bà trục tịch Trung Quốc tập cập bình sẽ sớm định đám để thảo gửa
các gửa mắt thương mạnh trong đó của chân chấp đến quan đến khoảng xa chiến lực.
Phát biểu trên trường trường trường phaystonation của Đi CBS,
ông bên xean cho biết Trung Quốc đăng hạn chế sức khẩu gáo và gliệu thiết yêu cho chuyện cùng
cũng công nghiệp của nổ và châu Âu.
D và mặc cầy đã đàn được giữa Mỹ và Trung Quốc về việc gửa mỏ thui quan và hạn chế thương mạnh được
về khoảng xa chiến lực. Ông bên xean cho biết cuộc định đám sắp tới ông trâm bống tập sẽ giúp lạm gió
liệu bất kinh đăng cố tình vì phạm, họ chỉ đến thần là Trung trặc ký thuật.
Tổng thống Mỹ trâm trước đó cũng khẳng định ông sẽ sơm nó chuyện với Trung tịch đáp.
Trong khi việc Trung Quốc hội thằng tư sân nhận 2 nhận đạo chưa lên là gần đây.
Cô vấn kinh tế nhà trắng Ké Vinh hai xean cho biết chưa còn ngày gửa thề cho cuộc định đám,
nhưng các bên đăng thảo lợi giúp lên quan đến thoả thuật đã được tại gần này của thằng trước về một số trang chấp thử quan.